all right so we are where I start in a
few minutes
probably a few seconds you don't mind
them Twitter
okay hello well thanks everyone for
joining the whole idea of this
livestream and we're thinking of doing
this as regularly as we can is obviously
the world is going through something of
a crisis right now around the around
kovat promo virus and part of that
obviously people are first and foremost
concerned about their in the community's
health and the spread of the virus and
how to best stop that
but then there's obviously site on
effects of that and one of them is that
we're starting to see increasing school
closures obviously other countries like
South Korea Japan and more recently
Italy and France have closed down
schools entirely and we're starting to
see that in the u.s. now my my
children's school was closed as of today
and obviously Khan Academy nonprofit
mission free world-class education for
anyone anywhere the way that we've tried
to help doing that is by creating
resources online that could be used in
conjunction with classrooms that could
also be used independently by students
we think we this is our duty to really
step up now and make sure that as many
students as possible feel as supportive
as possible as many parents as possible
feel supported as many teachers as
possible feel supported so what we're
going to do today and this is all a
little bit of improvisation is I'll tell
you what I've been telling you beginning
a lot of employees from from various
outlets and things I've been to I'll
tell you what we've been telling
everyone well what resources we're going
to try to put together and then I just
love to take questions from anyone out
there whether you're a parent student
teacher or just someone who's curious
about things so big picture what we're
saying
so first of all kind of having many of
y'all are familiar with it we do have a
lot of the core resources that students
of all ages will need to be able to keep
learning if you start at the youngest
age level we have kind of county kids
kind of Kevin kids as for as young as
ages 2 to 3 but it will adapt the
students all the way to through the
first grade standards we just add in the
first grade standards and that's in
reading writing math and
social-emotional learning we can talk
more about the ideal use case for it I
think for that younger crowd maybe 20
min today or at least no more than 20
minute sessions ideally you know sitting
on the lap or sitting next to a parent
or a loved one who can kind of work
through it with them but that could be
an interesting starting point we'll talk
more about some of the ways that you can
structure your day as you get into early
elementary middle Amenti late elementary
and you can middle school on the English
and language arts side we actually just
launched it's actually not even launched
it's a beta of our English and language
arts it's not perfect we have to make
some product changes so that it can
better work for the English and language
arts modality but it has some really
great content on it already so if you go
to the Khan Academy the main drop-down
menu on the top left you'll see when the
when the menu comes down you'll see it
on the bottom right it will say la beta
and then you can pick the appropriate
grade level once again up learn more
about how to use that but that has
reading comprehension which is I think
one of the most important things for
parents of students and teachers to keep
up with a while we're going through this
unfortunate situation on the math side
this is probably what we're most known
for a lot of people associated with
videos but actually I think the most
valuable thing we offer is the ability
for students to practice as much as they
need in any concept all standards
aligned at their own tiny pace that goes
all the way from the kindergarten
standards and so we do have an overlap
between Khan Academy kids and the
website where I would say if a student
is is just learning to read still quite
young kind of County kids it's a better
resource but if you look for the
kindergarten first grade standards but
if you're a you have a second grader who
could use the remediation or could use
to go back and for teachers say they
like to start all their students back at
kindergarten that actually could be
useful to just make sure they have no
swiss-cheese gaps but for sure once you
get to 2nd 3rd 4th grade all the way
through middle school high school and
college we we've got you covered on the
math side of things and then as you go
into a high school science and social
studies we have most of the four
subjects there as well and then on top
of that and we have the official SAT
practice which is which is math reading
it
I think that's appropriate for any high
school student and even some precocious
middle-school students if they want to
just make sure they get that practice in
those three areas and then for
enrichment I think our computer
programming is really a lot of fun and
it could be a really good way to spend
some downtime if students are at home
the thing that I'm emphasizing we're
emphasizing as a team to parents is try
to keep things you know don't try to do
everything all at once
it's not even healthy to be in front of
a screen for eight hours a day while the
schools are closed try to focus first on
just like the core fundamentals and then
if that's working then later on from
there in online the four fundamentals
are the reading the math and the writing
the reading you can use our English and
language arts for students to get
practice reading passages answering
comprehension questions on it so that's
a good source of reading practice and
also just reading books it's really that
simple we hope over the next week to
send out some reading lists and things
like that to make it easier for parents
and teachers and students on their own
to know what types of resources they can
look at on the math side depending on
the age range and we're going to send
out an archetype schedules over the next
week but for younger students I think
sessions of about 20 minutes is about
appropriate the important thing is to
just do the reading and do the math
every day that's what really makes a
difference that will keep students from
forgetting over this time period and and
I believe actually can help you push
them forward and if you can get that
reading and that math I would say even
two hours a day is just before base four
for students of any age I think you're
you're not going to be here regressing
over over this period and I might be
progressing and then from there you can
layer on more especially for older
students and I think what you get to
middle school and high school students
we can offer almost a full complete day
and we're also going to send other
resources that are out there podcasts
other things you can read magazines that
are good to read in dishonesty very
interesting time that I our globe is
facing so those are that's kind of the
initial of thinking right now if you go
to Khan Academy
you'll see a little banner that says hey
if you're seeing school closures because
of the virus click here and you'll see a
an evolving page that has our resources
how do you get started etcetera etcetera
and some of what I just talked about we
haven't put off yet so please come on a
daily basis it's going to be changing
regularly we're going to I'm hoping by
Monday or Tuesday we're going to put
those schedules up so if you if you are
a student or if you have a child or if
you're a teacher of children who are of
certain age groups
what could schedule look like for them
including things like brakes making sure
everyone gets time to run around play
and explore and pay attention to the
news and all of that but with that I'd
love to take questions that folks have
my colleague Irene she's got a laptop
here
hi everyone great questions in Spanish
I'll share some with you from Kristin
Allen we have the question of is there a
social-emotional learning on Khan
Academy for first and second anything so
thanks for the question so I'm kind of
going to be kids
we do have social-emotional learning
it's socialable for in this very broad
space but for Khan Academy kids that is
definitely integrated into that offering
and that's appropriate through students
up to six years old go through the six
year old standards but we don't have a
deep social emotional learning offering
on Khan Academy proper I think that is a
good call out and as we ramp up
materials I think it would be powerful
for us to think about how do we do that
too because a lot of what we've been
building over the many many years that
are I think going to be for free
valuable for people of this this period
they've been very focused on your core
academic but I think what we're going to
try to do this live stream was really
the first our first run at this is try
to give people a sense of community try
to give people sense of connectedness as
we are all socially isolating ISO to
speak and and also give folks materials
and things to do so you're going to see
all of us have Khan Academy broadening
what we're talking about I think you're
going
you know as you see the schedules and
things that we put out next week we're
gonna say this is you know this is your
time to this is your time to play this
is your time to meditate baby we're also
going to be exploring with other
partners ways if you can all interact in
deeper ways so that we don't all feel
completely isolated and also there's a
lot of learning that's going on in the
broader world right now
what's the virus how does it spread
what's the proper response to it what's
the economic implications of all of this
whether one of the what how is power our
social interactions going to change
maybe forever after this so there's a
lot of real-life learning that I think
kids could enact you all of us could
benefit from
yeah they're there a lot but it's an
Allen I just wanted to say that for
question was about the first and second
rates be sure to check out content you
can download that app there are no ads
in it no purchases and all the
characters really were designed
specifically ah specifically
I made that more effective morning to
clarify on the Facebook page they see my
name here because it's originating to
Facebook page you might be seeing
Philippe alive yeah that's still us it's
originating from from the video
management okay yeah is that the dual
nature and inside on the other side of
the screen some work this from I'm sorry
yeah yeah so that's a you know this is
this is a when we put out these we're
gonna hopefully by Monday or Tuesday
have schedules that you can say okay if
I have an elementary school estate
listening to a seven-year-old a 8 year
old what could the day look like for
that student and it's been a subpoena
wake up change out the PJs you know
really have a regular schedule find a
place in the house that feels like it's
not like you just slashed over on a
couch with the TV running and you're
trying to do a little burning on the
side it should feel like okay this is
kind of school we were actually going to
consult with more experts and hopefully
as we didn't want more of these live
streams which were we're targeting to do
on a daily basis
this crisis I'm hoping the briefs and
experts in who can help us with that too
but some of our first stabs at it would
be you know create incentives that
schedule will try to set up like a
checklist you might even try to kick
some frameworks that hey if a student is
able to do XY and z MK today here's some
some treats or some benefits they might
get there might be a little bit of quid
pro quo with your child but if they're
able to do this really focused good
screen time maybe they can get a little
bit of less academic screen time there
could be other benefits and you know one
of the things that we're trying to do
with these flash dreams is we want to be
a little bit of a clearinghouse - if
you're a parent who has come up with
really good frameworks we would send
them to us and he's kind of kept me all
the time in the summer or I've been
homeschooling the content so it needs
develop some tips or techniques about
how you motivate you please post them
and share the monocle communities yeah
my email um s conic khanacademy.org
email it to us if we see really cool
stuff we'll be sure to give you credit
we'll say hey this is what Fabia came up
v for for her children well you know
this is an adaptation of it it seems to
be working for her this could be good
for you know if you have seminary the
Royal children or whatever age group so
we're we're gonna be working on that
what are the what are the motivation
mechanisms another thing that we are we
are contemplating and we're trying to
figure out how we can root source this
and do this is are there ways that we
can we we can help kind of in real time
communicate with your children and
provide them some frameworks that during
the course of the day so that's
something that we're very seriously
looking at you for that you can do that
I'm still more question flowing in from
jennifer Goldstein problems with the
lessons online lessons online with Holly
so the lessons
Khan Academy has been building for the
building around a common flora firm
since the Common Core existed so the
lessons that you'll see in math from
Kate K through 12 the lessons you see on
Khan Academy kids and the lesson
in English language arts from which are
grades 2 through 8 on Khan Academy these
are not only aligned to the continent
for these most of them have had external
review from some of the even varied
people do not develop accounting for so
they are very very much standards
aligned if you're in a state that is at
the common core state I would say that
there's more alignment than you would
think as I'm a laureate a country for
that it's not enough that does not
follow the u.s. standards
virtually we have actually 40 there's 40
translated versions of Khan Academy if
you go to those website you'll see the
link at the top that banner the Spanish
is the most built out one but our belief
especially in a time like this
if if students are able to engage in
high-quality materials that are aligned
with better pay regular standard and
coming for is a traitor standard I'm
very confident in the opening will
progress in almost any standard that
that that's relevant I think the
important thing now with what's going on
with school closures is to just keep
students learning on high quality
materials make sure their reading skills
don't atrophy make sure their math
skills or after if you make sure that in
writing skills on a street and there
might be a glass-half-full opportunity
for them to maybe even get more practice
and this time a little bit more focus
okay I don't know if Jennifer was a
teacher but just in case for all the
teachers out there you can actually put
the Common Core standard things are
search box and then oldest I pull up the
videos from Jessica now do you think
this would be good for this time looking
for yes I think this is actually for
those of you don't know back in 2015 and
we created the partnership with the
College Board Khan Academy's official
practice for the SAT and it's not it
adds in math reading and writing today a
majority of all future tickets to use it
and you took the PSAT if students been
permission their spores can be linked
with their Khan Academy account I've
been it acts as kind of a diagnostic for
Khan Academy and as
one thing that we've always been focused
on both us and the College Board is we
don't view this as just SAT prep leave
you this is preparing you for college as
measured by the SCT and actually so the
SAT practice on factor method is an
excellent way to yes I said you can't
let to keep those reading comprehension
the math and the writing skills sharp is
actually a writing you can write and
it's auto graded by another partner
partner and so even if you're not taking
the SAT in the near term I think if
you're a ninth grader or above it can be
a great thing to engage them because
you're going to get practice in all of
the major domains and and and obviously
that will likely reflect and can improve
SAT score you know what at one of the
issues in high school normally is that
you're so overloaded you have six
classes you're taking and then you're
doing many hours of homework at night
and then you have to prepare for things
like SATs or other tests and you kind of
have to do that on the margin you could
view this as an opportunity to say hey
look you could put in as a high school
student if you're able to put in even an
hour a day on SAT practice maybe thirty
minutes on the on the English language
outside thirty minutes on the mat side
even that it's going to make a massive
gain and as a high school student or
parent of high school students I'm
assuming can have even more
self-regulation and you could spend some
more time so I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't do like five hours a day I
think that would not be healthy but if
you could do sessions of okay I'm going
to go deep for 40 minutes I'm gonna take
a 20-minute break I'm gonna go deep
again for 30 minutes take a 20-minute
break this is something full of fun with
our technique which is a technique for
avoiding procrastination which we all
struggle with many times and it is you
know set a timer that you're gonna be
focused to be 20 minutes 30 minutes 40
minutes I definitely recommend more than
40 minutes
and then at the end of that give
yourself another set the timer again and
give yourself a 15-minute graphic line
that's great to do whatever you want
hopefully something comfy go take for a
walk go for a run do something get
outside and then then dive back in and
if you're going to do the SAT practice
we've actually been doing some analytics
it's not Philippe ublic yet but the
important thing is you know not to just
is to do as much things that are
pushing you're learning as possible so
take those full length practices if you
can the recommendations we've seen some
associations that the students are able
to follow the recommendation because
you're always trying to push you but
then potentially seeing more gains and
the case of colleges are randomly
jumping around on it so simple answer is
yes I think the SAT practice is a very
good way to stay engage in in all the
core of something and in the math
movement okay and that questions only
and so now we actually have from from
another con a teeth mom um are you
planning to coordinate with teachers
semesters yes we had a webinar yesterday
and then this is just what you're seeing
right now is just the very tip of the
iceberg and you hope to kind of go for
this to build momentum so we hope to
throughout this whole for lack of a
better word crisis we hope to connect
with teachers support teachers we're
trying to talk to other technology
platforms and figure out what type of
resources we might be able to you know
let's go we also want to be Clearing
House if you find out that a someone has
figured out the teacher has to figure
out a good way to virtualize their
classroom you want to share it with
folks obviously not just using resources
like Khan Academy whatever resources are
out there but yes we want to support
teachers through this transfer this and
teach and then students to do some
practical ways to get started so I'm for
teachers specifically we have a teach
live Congress so just gonna teach with
you'll be able to connect with all types
of teachers and make movie tips to get
started if you get our homepage can hit
put that little blue ribbon um I'll take
you to kind of like a blog article and
we'll link to can the teacher resources
so we'll just have all sorts of like
videos webinars and resources to help
you get let's see and we have from Olin
Minka I'm sorry if I am is there a
solution for remote places for internet
access to them so open
you know we don't have a really elegant
solution there you know our apps kind of
coming kid says work offline and Khan
Academy our Khan Academy main app does
allow you to store some of your content
but and it we don't have a really good
off truly offline solution for the
mainstream Khan Academy here that is one
of the gaps you know obviously around
the world we know that's an issue and in
this situation I know a lot of public
schools are struggling with this issue
of if we close the school which is
probably prudent at this point for
spreading the virus how do you ensure
that all kids have access now we are
fully accessing there's content yes it
used to be known as k-lite yeah Colibri
which is an offline so you could look
into that and that's spelled Kol I Bri
look into that yes and maybe even if you
do search for kami life it might show up
as well and that one is something I
think that's really valuable if you're
able to look you should look into it I
actually haven't looked recently at look
there's activity ideas but but then I
think that's more of a look yeah people
should look into that I think that's a
little harder for an individual to
continue on their own
but a bishop they should try our team
just wants to remind us that you can
those download the videos let's see we
also have from Melinda wedding are there
any plans that help
18:50 might be missing the last baby
yeah that's an excellent question
actually I mean what's the you know what
we're gonna all going to try to make you
know what we can of this situation you
could actually use as a glass-half-full
because traditionally a pee test which I
know there's things that students want
time to prepare for the rigorous exams
it's usually hard as you go into may
students have all their other classes on
their other homework and then between
the gaps and to prepare for AP this
could be I don't know where the College
Board is on I know some of the SAT
administrations have been moved around I
don't know what's going to happen
in key administration's I hope they move
forward or maybe they've delayed a
little bit we'll see we don't know what
the world is but if you like it for much
less May but I think it is prudent for
kids to assume that the testing is going
to happen as as scheduled and I think
that's where we can be really little
helpful for folks we have on Khan
Academy in calculus DP statistics ap
biology ap physics we were actually in
development of art above the new version
of our AP chemistry but we have
chemistry at the high school and college
level on site we have AP microeconomics
macroeconomics American history ap
government and civics ap's computer
science principles and so I would
recommend if the students are able to
put now they have more time if they are
able to put 30 minutes a day 40 minutes
a day an hour a day into each of the
subjects that they found ticking for the
AP test and come May I think they're
going to do very very well as I
mentioned earlier it's what we have
visit this videos its exercises and
these exercises have been vetted by
third parties these are the same third
parties from tough develop things like
ap or so many pieces of operating the AP
so it really is highly rigorous
materials so what I would recommend is
throw on Khan Academy every course we
have many most of our courses we have
something called mastery enabled what
that means is not only do we have
exercises but it's it's enabled in a way
that it can be a mechanic to try to
measure of students knowledge state on
the various skills
if a student is already feeling like
they covered most of the year in an AP
class they can go immediately to what's
called the course challenge and take
that first challenge which should take
from about 40 minutes 45 minutes and
then they'll see which units they are
strong or weakened and then especially
the units that they're weakened they can
then go to the each of those units and
there's things called unit tests and
then based on that and they'll take
about 30 minutes and then they can get a
skill breakdown with your skills in yes
and then they can go skill by skill and
the way that you get you level up the
skills you can either go to a particular
skill and get a certain percentage of
them right every time and we have a very
deep item bank so they really shouldn't
see a lot of free peaks and then and
then if you see that feeling
in mixed skill practice on you the test
for a force challenge or what we now
have is a home master challenge just
spaced repetition review then only get
leveled up so I'm actually very
confident that if students if we're
taking AP put in 30 minutes to an hour
per day for AP they actually going to be
quite prepared and then I would add as
you get to like the last few weeks of
the AP to augment that with Khan Academy
well I think prepared very well for the
multiple-choice portion of the AP for
the free response portion of the AP and
most of the APS we have worked examples
of free response and so there I would
recommend and pettite the student you
know start the video pause it right
before I'm about or one of our team
members is about to work through the
example and then work through themselves
before the video that's it that's the
best way to kind of consume that contact
but yeah I think ap is a very powerful
use case for students s relatively great
and we're getting close tonight there's
another question time our staff attend
four weeks week
okay right now I'm from cheated on D can
parents assign things to kid I know I
can do so if it's a cure but wasn't sure
about so there's two things so first of
all we you know the what we used to call
coaches or teacher tools are available
to anyone it's not like you check the
Shubert a certified teacher when you
it's predominately used by teachers so
we have both parent tools and teacher
tools the teacher tools are more
powerful they're built to be able to
support a larger number of students and
things like that and so from the teacher
tools for sure you can make assignments
you can assign specific skills you can
assign full units you can assign things
like unit tests you can assign things
like force masteries I want students to
achieve mastery in the subject by a
certain date on the parent side you can
definitely monitor what I would say if
you want to do assignments the safest
thing to teach it's yeah
that's actually where we have more
sophisticated tools anyway and we'll
just be a teacher with however many kids
you have as your students let's see from
from Satya this is a great question
for us to start thinking about how can
the teachers
reach out to students or in school users
yeah we're brainstorming I know you know
my school district are our teachers and
students just talking about that and
we're going to start off with it the
easiest most familiar to some other
school systems I didn't pass through or
perfect system for that communication
and maybe this question also means but
continue to process communities when
you're teaching online I think so what
we're gonna try to do and this is all
improvisation and I think we're all
improvising over the next few weeks is
so so putting all aside all the things
that were able to do I think there might
be a kind of a convergence here is there
is a world where if you do have Google
need to give me some of these other
tools that allow some form of video
conferencing and messaging at the same
time it would be I think pretty cool for
for for teachers to be able to
communicate students that look I'm going
to be available at these times you know
obviously it could be coordinated with
schools of all I do know some schools my
children school or that they they're
essentially burn they're trying to
schedule is going to be 90% the same and
they're going to be using these types of
video conferencing tools to essentially
run their program now that's kind I
would say that's the best case and we
know that that's a lot of schools don't
have time to plan and do that kind of
thing so I would say I think would be
would be interesting if at the same time
that we put out what kind of archetype
schedules would look like for students
in different age groups we could be
really interesting if teachers are able
to also message with their students and
say hey if you follow the schedule and
obviously at that schedule whatever you
think is perfect for your students if
you follow the schedule I
I - I the teacher I will be available at
these times
Epic's link on this Google hangout or on
the Skype link or whatever else and then
you can actually have kind of a virtual
station rotation model because some of
your students okay it's 9:00 a.m. the
schedule says work on your Khan Academy
math for half an hour but the students
also know that you as a teacher are
available so they have any questions
they can go to you and literally could
just change the window and say hey you
know and sounds like office hours and so
some big students might be working with
you and then you can do deeper problems
or more challenging problems or you can
eat might be able to kink some students
on the tools like slack or some message
or something like that say hey I see
you're having trouble if you can look at
the Khan Academy dashboard I see you're
struggling on this concept why don't you
come into my office hours essentially
open up a different tab and I want to
work with you okay so I think that's
that that could be really really cool if
students are able to get that type of
support while they're working on tools
like like Khan Academy and obviously it
as a teacher you able to do the lesson
plans that you were already planning to
do that that's even cooler and you know
even in the classroom you think the best
use case is teachers are able to do
their traditional lesson plan highly
collaborative ways and that there's
twenty thirty percent of the time
students really personalize learning on
platforms like like Khan Academy the
teachers are still being able to see
what work and kids are working on what
we're struggling with and where
interventions were perfect but in this
type of a context it might it might make
sense to have more of the student self
work but has a lot of support from from
teachers okay let's see from Rossi they
have a question as a lots of home school
my children if you have any
recommendations I do want to look off
the bat mention that we actually have a
current webinar mark their calendars is
next Wednesday and Neely will also be
reporting it and makes that before in
live yeah
okay you can register for that yeah so
the parent webinar and you know the
simple answer is everything we've been
talking about on this livestream I think
is relevant if you're looking for home
school or your child depending on the
age group as I said you know most of the
resources sorry we have office light
from my clients um most of most of the
resources you need
we Khan Academy is been working on it
for many years so you know math for sure
we can help students learn at their own
time in face starting as early as pre-k
with Khan Academy kids which goes to
first grade and then you can pick up
from there all the way through high
school and early college mathematics oh
I'm Khan Academy students can learn at
their own time and pace we're going to
try to put up we only have a lot of
materials out there things like the
webinar going to be really valuable for
getting a little bit more tactical help
but we're going to put a lot of
resources out there for it for different
age groups
what could the schedule look like where
one of the Khan Academy resources that
can be relevant in each of those periods
in the schedule and then all there what
other resources should folks have into
books that might be available online or
not online a podcast it could be good
sources of discussion so we're going to
try to support you as much as possible
the reality is a large chunk of the
world is being forced to home-school on
some on some level so I think it's just
oh yeah what we're gonna do on that
Sophia please tell us what question
keeps telling us the questions you have
as I said before my email is s con at
khanacademy.org we want your questions
your ideas things have worked for you we
would love to then share with everyone
else yeah we really appreciate what's
been rolling in I know that Jeremy the
color teacher webinar last night has
already had like a list of 1318 a survey
we sent out so what we're doing is we're
calling through all of your questions so
that we can kind of create and get the
experts in and feed the webinars and the
tips that you're gonna keep on doing
this look yeah other questions
he flew let's see from Sean Rose does
your from you being to teach concepts
and he
talk about having it sound on Cystic at
home and wasn't able to make it through
this multiplication tables and until
they found an online
yeah so to some degree is a simple
answer I think Khan Academy kids is is
the richest and that's for younger kids
that's a very rich game-like environment
as you get into the main core Khan
Academy we have some game mechanics we
have things like energy points mastery
points avatars your the whole mashing
mechanic to try to level them up
confetti when you reach certain levels
on the side so we have those types of
game mechanics but it isn't like a you
know there's a spectrum between game and
and academic learning and we always said
look we got we got to make sure we cover
the standards and then how can we layer
as much game implementation mechanics on
top of that but you know we're
constantly trying to improve that every
year we try to make improvements to make
it even more engaging for students you
brought up a really interesting flight
around multiplication well actually are
them two things you know we haven't done
official studies of Khan Academy with
students with various learning needs
whether they're on mystic spectrum or
whether other issues other other
learning needs ADHD or dyslexia but we
have had a lot of anecdotal feedback
that being able to learn at your own
time and pace being able to get as much
practice and feedback as you need you
have some game mechanics being able to
pause repeat in watch videos at
different speeds is is valuable for
folks on the point you brought up about
the multiplication teams I think that's
a super valuable one you know kind of
kind of a gives practice on things like
that but nothing can be and this is just
a great bonding experience for that some
of that you know if your child is second
grade third grade fourth grade
make sure they have that fluency in
there under format and then for math
facts we can give a lot of practice on
the different standards on Khan Academy
but there's nothing like sits sitting
with your with your mom or dad or
you're a teacher and you know making
sure you have your single-digit addition
math facts really fluent and making and
then what you get to about second or
third grade making sure you have your
multiplication or math facts really
really fluent I can't tell you how many
students we've seen we're in fourth or
fifth grade or sixth period and
sometimes high school who you can still
tell they paid too much of their
cognitive load is trying to figure out
what eight times nine is so they can't
focus on the other math and so you'll be
doing your kids a big favor if I just
make sure they're super fluent with that
stuff if they if they're not there
already we're going to be doing yeah I
think that's the hope you know this is a
it's been great a lot of folks have
chimed in I know this is a super tough
time for a lot of folks a lot of folks
are trying to figure out I mean I you
know yesterday I was working from home
and my kids were all right next to me I
do want to do a quick shout out to
Teresa brand she just said thank you
solve for this live stream because there
are so many brands out there I'm feeling
panicking but I think what's your
message if your yeah well you know
Teresa appreciate that I think the you
know one of the the main purposes of
starting this live stream today is that
we're all in this together we're parents
everyone's effect you know long people
affair we're all trying to figure out
this way and we're in the new
we're in a new society has never gone
through this at least in modern times
and I think for all of us obviously for
me to see if in fact it's all right now
it's comforting to me as well because
I've been socially absolutely and and so
I think the best thing we can do you
know thank thank God that we have these
types of resources so that we can
connect virtually right now but that's
what I think it is it's I think this is
going to be a time that we see the best
of humanity will step forward it's our
duty to kind of help all of all of y'all
parents teachers students to navigate
this period we're going to be back on
Monday I hope to be able to do this
every day and don't be surprised if this
grows into more types of supports so
that as many people possible or are not
feeling panicky I highly recommend
meditation we've actually reported some
guided meditations recently something
that I've been doing for the last year
and a half I I was getting quite
claustrophobic on planes and someone
recommended meditation that really
helped me reduce my claustrophobia but
it had had positive effects well beyond
just my plane foster phobia so I highly
recommend that especially people feeling
anxious and it's feeling a little wrong
but I think you know just ten minutes a
day five minutes a day just sit silently
try to observe your thoughts realize
that everything's going to get better in
the end you just have to just put one
foot in front of the other and just do
the next right thing you know so to my
showing it to myself and like my
children history because there was like
what's going on just like look let's
just not let's just do that next right
thing for the next hour the next day the
next week it's all going to work out I
think there's going to be some
glass-half-full moments and what I think
we can see the best of everyone step or
and we'll do opt on our side so thanks
everyone for being part of this I'll do
the next right thing for the next hour
then okay